[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys anna welcome back to
the leia hile pen show powered by
iconplus as always
and sponsored by blockfi so since this
is powered by iconplus a really quick
news announcement for you guys from the
icon network
so icon is another step closer to the
full launch of icon 2.0
as the test net is now live this is one
to watch as this blockchain upgrade is a
power boost to
the icon network for next level d5 and
even more enterprise adoption so as
always
more news coming from the open network
which is really great to hear so
i also want to say thank you to my
sponsors block five so i actually use
them to earn up to eight point six
percent
on my usdc so if you don't know uscc is
a stable coin pegged to the us dollar
so i'm gonna leave a link in the
description and in the comments
um because at the moment they actually
have an offer you can earn up to
actually you can get up to 275 depending
on how much you deposit with them
and i think that's only for limited time
only so i'm going to leave that in the
comments
and in the description wherever you're
watching you'll find the link
so back to the leia hill plan show today
i have a really cool guest somebody who
has been
in the space um for quite a long time
some might call him
a bit of an og and he also has one of
the biggest
youtube accounts it is of course
box mining michael how you doing hey
how's it going how's it going a great
intro thank you so much
yeah absolute pleasure you've been in
the space what three years
four years longer am i being really fast
too long too long i mean okay so um you
guys know
box mining it started off you know as
mining so
um started very very early so this is
like
2012 early so this was like when i was a
student
studying in university and i was like oh
what can i do in my spare time
so at this time it wasn't like at a in a
professional basis you know i knew
more about covalent bonds and about
bitcoin and finance right so
that time it was just like pure nerding
out and
mining so to speak then more towards
2016 that was when i took it a lot more
seriously this is when
you know i think we'll talk about it i
mean you have a quite a
you have a few questions and i think it
leads up to it but
long story short um i've been for a ride
where i didn't know much about crypto
and it was really in 2016 i really said
you know what i really want to know a
little bit more about it
um it's more than something you know
just click buttons on farm
and it was kind of discovering that kind
of the world
it's like taking the red pill right like
the world's kind of a lie and the
finance system is kind of a lie
and you know what it what is the federal
reserve it's not really federal
really but anyway so so it was that when
i took us
quite uh a little bit more seriously
started channel box mining
and with the help of the community and
together discussing everything
you know i learned a lot about what the
fundamental value of this whole space is
and that kind of grew not just to the
space in general but also
with the whole kind of the blockchain
revolution coming with ethereum
decentralized finance everything we're
kind of like very very
deep into this now so yeah um that's
what
it looks like kind of very short yeah
yeah well firstly i love your energy
because i know it is 11 p.m for you
so i love your energy
yeah of course and i want to go back a
little bit because actually you
mentioned
2012 so that's actually insane and i
know you weren't taking it seriously but
how on earth did you first hear about
cryptocurrencies
and then i wasn't going to talk about
this but since you mentioned it
i want to talk about that red pill
moment but we'll get there so first
you're thinking back to 2012
how did the world look you said you were
a student what happened
poor poor student i mean um i'm actually
lucky because i'm in science right
so um being a science um i was actually
doing a post-grad course so i was doing
a phd at that time
so i kind of wanted some extra income
right so as a postgrad student you get a
very small stipend for
doing teaching assistant stuff so you
know that's a very very small amount you
make very very little money
right so i wanted some extra money on
the side and
at that time there were two things i'm a
big big gamer so
i kind of know the economy of video
games through and through
and also i played a lot of video games
so at that time i had these computers
that were able
to perform a lot of operations let me
see if we can find something cool for
you
but um
so this is like one of the early
graphics cards um i was just using as a
prop
um this is actually like uh kind of this
i would say is a 2015 model so it's a
little bit older
the oldest ones are gone but yeah like
you have these graphics cards
and i was figuring out you know how can
you make money with graphics cards right
so it was just like okay look
there's this thing called bitcoin you
get mining and like these priorities on
and
you can mine and you can get this thing
called bitcoin
it was worth ten dollars you care about
it though
i don't know it's internet forums you
know you just search these things like
you know late at night you're like okay
look i'm a poor student i
need to get some beer money somehow all
right and
so yeah so i i didn't i don't know how i
stumbled upon i think it was a forum or
something but they're like oh we can
mine
bitcoin with graphics cards i'm like
okay cool i got like three computers
don't ask me why longer story right
there
but i was like okay let me just power
these computers on my big mine bitcoin
and um yeah i got like 0.3 bitcoin a day
so it sounds like a lot today
three bitcoin point three bitcoin back
in the day at ten dollars was
like what three dollars and it's not
really per day it's like kind of like
1.5 days right because there's a mining
uncertainty there but
occasionally you'll get this email be
like yo just point three bitcoin coming
in to your
mining pool address you know what you
want to do with it so
anyways back in the day it was you know
three bucks it was less
than anything like some people said you
know what you know this is like
uh it's worse than picking up cans off
the street right if you pick the cans
off the street
at least you'll probably be making like
seven dollars an hour
but anyways no that's funny because
actually because when i was at
university i was doing i was giving out
flyers
and i'd be lucky if i got seven dollars
an hour so
exactly this is money when you're
sleeping right i got free electricity
right
three dollars every other ever every day
every 1.5
it's not that bad right it's not that
bad so so that was kind of the initial
story because at that time bitcoin was
mineable by gpus right
so at that time i didn't really know
what it is you know i didn't read
through them
like what it is i'm just like oh there's
some crazy guys trying to make some
digital currency no one's gonna
use it you know uh so yeah and also of
course you just watch
like news and you're like oh peter
shifts like shouting yo bitcoin is going
to go to zero
uh it sucks it's uh it's people are
delusional right
so then uh when bitcoin pumped from 10
to 15 i was like 50
pump in a day you know
sell it all dump it i don't i don't
care right it's gonna go to zero right
peter shift man he's right
he's he's on to something right so uh
big mistake obviously then i forgot
about everything and then like i think
it's 2014 my dad called me i was like yo
you got some bitcoin because like it's
like a thousand something right now
right like and you sold it at ten
dollars right
yeah like how do you feel about that
how do you feel um
it took me a while so um this is kind of
the story right so when in 2014 when
you're wrong
right when you're wrong the first time
you don't want to admit being wrong
you're like oh this is going to go to
zero right and you're you're
you're hating yourself but at the same
time you're like you want yourself to be
right
right you know you want to know like
like you know in those dark moments
you'll think of how much bitcoin could i
have had right and then like
and oh like if i sold it now it'd
be crazy but
so um 2012 uh 2012 to 2014 so
2014 that was roughly when that happened
and then i was like you know what
let me get on with my life you know i
it's like
this is just too crazy you know it's too
late for me
i don't care blah blah blah um
and then i came so so it's like it just
just yeah just went on another two years
kind of passed until 2016 right
so that was when i said you know what
i'm going to snap myself out of this
kind of
a hole you know i discovered bitcoin
early that's great
but i made mistakes that's early it's
great amid those mistakes come clean
about that and
um in my spare time i was like you know
what i let me start youtube channel and
just talk about that
so that's kind of yeah i wanna i'm gonna
get to i'm gonna get to the youtube
channel but
i'm not done with the story so
back in the day people must have thought
you're absolutely mad
playing with this digital currency which
i think
at the time you know people obviously
thought for whatever reason was
um a criminal so what did you what did
you do and i think
actually maybe you didn't actually face
this just because you're quite fortunate
you came from that gaming and that
computer science kind of
or science kind of background so maybe
you didn't receive as much as that of
that
i think it's not as much i mean um a few
things right
um the media really wants to bash
bitcoin and you kind of believe it
you're like
okay look it's um you know it's it's
backed by some sort of like money
laundering there was a silk road back
then you know
yeah i was a straight kid right i'm like
i don't do drugs and i'm like if i
did i'll probably be like going on like
oh what's a silk road let me check this
out but
you know i'm just too dumb for that so
um
too much of a good boy that's what we
like dude
like i'm science chemistry background i
could have been breaking bad by then but
you know i chose to be like you know
legit right like let's go let's just
save the world you know let's make it a
better place you know cure cancer
just to jump in they often say that some
of like the science and medical students
they're the most
die-hard party kind of students that
there are so
some are some are but i was like i was
like i was too good for that i'm like
you know i have to be superior better
than everyone else right i'm like i'm
too good for that
those guys are junkies you know i'm too
good i'm gonna like you know save the
world of cancer or something
right
so um so yeah yeah and i i actually did
do cancer research it just took a damn
long time
um it was like painful so anyways um
so not in that sense um i don't think i
got that much
like criticism for that i think that's
like
um yeah it wasn't that bad but
i think yeah you know but you know
looking back at it you can kind of think
like
yeah it's just all fun right like
nowadays you have a completely different
lens but
you know back in the day you would be
like kind of persuaded by media because
you think oh media is legit right
like these truths know what they're
talking about so
yeah of course yeah i know 100 agree
with you but i think i think it makes
sense
that you probably didn't really face
that much just because of the community
that you are in
like when i first heard a bitcoin i
think it was 2012 as well
i didn't get involved or anything but um
that's when i first heard of it and i
heard about it through
the whole silk road buying drugs online
kind of things that's how i first heard
of it
but you mentioned earlier the federal
reserve and i really want to talk about
this i wasn't going to ask you
but hey we're here so if you could
briefly explain
what actually is the problem with our
traditional financial system i think
we keep banging on about it don't we um
but
like i don't think half the people here
probably really
could explain to let's say their friends
their parents
um what the problem really is because i
think for me i often
find it quite it's kind of like once
you're red pill it's kind of like that
obvious
thing and it's really hard to verbalize
so other than you know inflation and the
printing of money and all this stuff
what would you say it's kind of funny
right i think it really goes back
to power right yeah and
it turns out that a lot of things we
assume it's not real
so like i thought i used to think that
the federal reserve was a federal entity
it's not right
it's a it's a collection of banks so i
highly recommend the book the creature
from jekyll island
so this book kind of explains the kind
of evolution of how
the federal reserve came to be and it's
like
it definitely does take its political
like this definitely has a stance i mean
when you're reading the book you know
this is this book is obviously
opinionated because the creature from
jekyll island refers to
the federal reserve basically a bunch of
bankers just met up on jekyll island
very secretly
to form this kind of way to control
money right and obviously this benefits
them the most
yeah and i think this kind of goes to
the very core
of what we believe is money and
authority and power
so at the end of the day we kind of are
taught as kids
that we should believe authority like
trust your teachers you know refer to my
like i had a
you know i'm sure you should you can
relate like british education system i
was like mister whatever
mr bag you know it's the headmaster
right so uh we're taught to conform from
a very very young age
yes we're taught to conform but i'm i am
thankful that during the
end of the formative british education
days during the a levels you start to
you start they start to ask you to
question
which is great right so towards the end
but
early on it's not and you kind of
believe the system for out
right you believe that the people who
are creating money who are controlling
money
you know they're benign figures they're
trying to do the best job they can
you know and that's that's kind of the
biggest lie
that the system can tell you right so
once you take the red pole you guys
start a question okay what are these
entities
and are they trying to serve our
interest or their interest
right and i think that's the power of it
that's the kind of the power and the
broken part of not just the financial
system and it starts
it starts off with you question the
financial system okay what is this what
is this money i have i actually have um
um this is something weird there's a one
us dollar i was just um
i had a debate this morning but it
wasn't anyways it's interesting so one
u.s dollar but
it's kind of interesting because um back
in the day u.s dollar was pegged
to the gold standard right so they're
saying you know what this this money has
value derives value because
at the end of the day it's backed by
gold and they can't
artificially create make more gold out
of nothing
but they broke that gold standard they
could do due to war times etc
and the value of the dollar kept
dropping and i thought
you know initially when i read the
report i was like oh the value of the us
dollar dropped
by uh by 70
97 i thought okay that figure um
it doesn't mean much but if you really
think about it right like
it literally dropped like to nothing
right like if a cryptocurrency drops its
value by 90
plus it's dead right it's like you would
it's gone right but that's what happened
to the dollar over time and
it's because of the way those financial
systems kind of rigged and designed
so you know this is kind of explained to
gold bugs right they're like okay the
gold bugs are constantly saying look
this is
way more like gold is way more
legitimate than the dollar
and then you kind of start questioning
of course not just
the like i said just not just the
federal reserve but also
the world governments right and then
that's that's when it gets really messed
up so i feel like it's multiple levels
of understanding
and i think the latest understanding
that's quite depressing too it's like
you know um i have a friend that
literally said you know international
law is so interesting
and international politics is on the
street because there is no law
okay
there's just really dark stuff i mean
like
especially what's happening in between
us and china
um and you can kind of read the
undertones for it like
like i don't want to get discuss
politics too much it's gonna get trigger
people a lot but uh i'll say it
you know you just have to be careful
right like if you say the wrong things
you do disappear
um like it's like if
it sounds weird but no matter where you
are whether in the states whether in
china whether in the uk
you think you have rights and liberties
right but until a certain point
until a certain point where um
you can just suddenly disappear so i'm
with you
i'll leave it ominous at like that uh
look at what happened to ok x right like
they literally made a message that said
yo we
can't find star anymore like
starshu you know our ex-ceo who has
all the keys to your cryptocurrency
deposits
well we can't contact him anymore he's
cooperating with authorities
yeah i mean i'm totally with you i think
and that's one of the main reasons for
me why i've kind of chosen to delve into
this space more and essentially stay
here
just because it is independent from
those liberties and
whatever you know those freedoms and
liberty so i sort of imagine i won't ask
you too much on this but i sort of
imagine that you're not too pleased with
the increasing restrictions that we've
seen
um following you know the whole
coronavirus thing i just wondered what's
it like in hong kong
yes or no i mean from a science
background
um i said very early and i covered
coronavirus very early right
because um it came from um
wuhan china and i was one of the first
like
in fact i covered it when um i actually
had to cancel my trip back to china at
that time there were no quarantine
like it's nothing but it was just like i
was like this is the right thing to do
like i was gonna visit my parents over
chinese new year and i was like you know
what
uh let me just cancel it so um i covered
it and
we actually found out quite a lot you
know like the fact that it was way more
dangerous than initially thought
i mean i think the rest of the
international community was just like
jumping around
uh literally not looking at facts for
like
until february right so it's like they
squandered like
the whole literally squandered like
a lot of valuable time um i think that
there was a time when like i don't want
to argue too much about this right
because like yes
and it's so political right and then
like from a scientific
perspective right this was something
that they could have prevented
very early on and we could have
completely kind of eliminated it
um very early on if we did the necessary
steps very early on
so i felt like this was a situation
where i think it was 100
percent um preventable in hong kong we
now have no cases
um no domestic you have any lockdown or
anything
yes we did so um okay so
hear me out before people go all crazy
and stuff and i think a lot of people
like they hated me for wearing a mask
and all that weird stuff but hong kong
is a very very densely populated place
um if you ever go to mong kok or
chimchar choi you'll see
you know you have no personal space like
you know you go in america you know your
personal space is 1.5 meters
right here in hong kong your personal
space is literally touching the next
person next to you right
so um yeah the virus could have hit us
very very hard here but it was a very
clear case that people wore masks very
early on and that really did contain the
spread like this
hong kong could have been obliterated by
this so i would say 100
you know um people are like protesting
mass and stuff you know you know what
just get your head out of your ass
um it depends on where you are obviously
if you're in you know the wilderness
and whatever it doesn't spread but you
know at the end of the day
like speaking from a country where the
population density is insane here
i think you know hong kong did something
right but okay you know we didn't have
some lockdowns et cetera blah blah blah
you know long story cut short
i think honestly there are some
screw-ups too i won't get into it it's
just like from a scientific perspective
i just want to go to politicians and
just slap them in the face and say yo
you know what
you kill people and um it's just
shameful you guys just
screwed it up completely okay all right
well there you go
we'll leave the corona virus
but i think that's super interesting so
thanks for sharing our thoughts on that
just because you are obviously very
close to
china being being in hong kong more
close than i am so
that's super interesting to hear your
points um okay so like i said earlier
you are one of the biggest crypto
youtube channels so tell me about how
you actually
started it how has it been because you
know keeping up that kind of momentum
constantly is a lot and also is this
your is this what you do full time
um lots of questions there all right
yeah
so thanks for the compliments i think um
one of the channels that
grew and blew up in 2017 i'm very
grateful for that i'm really grateful
for the community
and i have some people who really
appreciate the content and i want to say
you know i really appreciate everyone's
feedback
too so just shout out to everyone on
telegram and on
youtube etc so yeah definitely big shout
out to you guys i think it's really cool
so um i learned a lot from that um and
from 2016 onwards
it became both content creation and also
investing in a space
so um 2017 i was trying to balance both
and it was hell
like literally um going to conferences
and then trying to create comp content
at conferences and then trying to figure
out what people like
and then sometimes people like it
sometimes people don't you know that's a
that's a thing of content creation right
you know
sometimes they love you for it sometimes
they hate you for it and then sometimes
they love it
love you for it like six months later
after they you know screamed at you for
it so it's kind of funny
um and then from 2018 2019 i'm kept up
with it and
now as well so now what i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to keep up a live stream
so guys
um catch me tomorrow i'll be online in
roughly
less than 12 hours actually so on my
channel as well
so i'll be do i'll do live streams
monday and friday
and i try to create content outside but
to be honest i've been investing a lot
um that has been a primary focus of 2020
where
because i have so much money on the
market it's
no longer very viable for me to
um like aggressively create content so
that's the unfortunate side effect of
being in crypto but
at the same time you know money is great
right so um that's the kind of the
honest truth
so it's kind of a final balance like
maybe i'll kind of correct back to
making content more later and
you know we'll kind of balance that out
yeah it is about finding the balance
and you often hear you know even if it's
not in the crypto community just about
general creators that you get creative
burnout don't you because yeah
it's just constantly and you've achieved
so much and you're even one of you're
like i'm saying earlier um but before we
went live we were chatting and i was
sort of saying to you that
i actually go to your channel when i'm
confused about something and i want to
learn more about it so
yeah i think back in like july i was
watching your stuff about d5 you're one
of the first
people to actually put up content about
d5 yield farming um even nfps
um oh my god that's crazy it's that's
nuts
it's just absolutely crazy yeah yeah
yeah go for it so how about your story i
mean like
um i think you created content now
you're in um independent how was that
oh you want to hear about me okay i want
to hear about you i want to care about
you i mean
yeah maybe we could do that are we
switching all right what do you want to
try what's switching what's switching i
just want to see
like you know as a content creator how
do you find that balance because like
i'm struggling man i'm like yeah i'm i'm
like
i'm like having a hard time yeah oh gosh
it is a lot
um it's a really good question and i've
not thought about this so i'm gonna
think about it as i speak
okay so here we go everybody watching
live okay
um it's tricky i think you have to
prioritize
um the most effective things and
you can either spread yourself in or you
can really prioritize what's most
effective so like for me personally i'm
really prioritizing twitter
um i think it's really effective um i
think you know if you compare it to
platforms like linkedin
i've never ever gone any work through
linkedin um
ever which is absolutely hilarious to
think about it i've only ever gone to
work through twitter so i'm really
pushing my twitter i'm also pushing
tick-tock
um because i think tick-tock is the next
big thing
um so in terms of balancing i don't know
i just keep going
i don't know i drink wine and it helps i
don't know what to say
i don't really know i drink wine and it
helps that's it that's it that's a good
answer that's a good answer yeah i think
i think you're having fun i think that's
the i that's what i get you know
like i saw some content creators um and
they got really severe burnout because
they're trying to manage the job
and they're also trying to create
content and i was doing that when i
first started right and i was like no
yeah like at some point you need to do
this full time you also need to have
some fun
but also i i've been having a hard time
balancing work or life uh work life as
well because the d5 thing caused me to
literally work like 15 hour days during
like the yo far many times right because
you're like you're literally chasing up
every aft
new farm right the new opportunity pops
up and then even like this week i mean
um people know keeper like keeper just
popped out and like i had a split second
to make a decision whether to buy it or
not
it's like like oh it's andre cronie's
new project what is it i don't know
but like every second like actually not
every second i think it went
up um 26 x in the first 26 minutes so
every minute
is um a 1x from the original uh
price so you're like you know like that
that's a lot of psychological pressure i
feel like that's kind of the crypto
thing like
you're combining both price like
speculation pressure combine that
with um a content creator pressure and
actually can like take a huge toll so
i'm like i'm super impressed that you do
so much content you know you
consistently do it
i think that's pretty cool like that's
that's awesome
i appreciate that that's really nice
yeah i mean i'm just kind of like
doing what i can and pushing through and
i think you make a really good point i
think it's really difficult to do that
content creator thing
while having a full-time job so i think
this is just what i do full-time i guess
it's what you do full-time
in terms of balancing the whole social
life that's a really interesting topic
so
i just sort of feel like given
everything right now with lockdown
because
like europe lockdown is still huge okay
so not that i'm based in germany or
france but germany and france have just
gone
into um another lockdown
yeah yeah so they've just gone into
another lockdown and the uk
has gone is going that way anyway so i
haven't really had any socializing
available
so i thought you'd be like i because i i
talked to some people in europe and
they're like they're just driving like
the convertible around between france
and germany and like oh my god that is
life right
i got something no really that sucks
it's like
um yeah like i was like
quite surprised to be honest like um
what was it like because in hong kong we
can't really leave so basically in hong
kong if you
um if you leave you're going to be
quarantined right so you don't want to
come back and
you know it's the same in europe so i'm
in romania right now and when i got to
romania i had to quarantine for two
weeks
and when i go back to the uk i have to
quarantine for two weeks but i don't
think i'm going to the uk i think i'm
going to go somewhere else
but i want to keep chatting and i want
to talk to you um about
what is going on in the market okay so
it's been really
really interesting i want to get your
thoughts on bitcoin i want to get your
thoughts on potential new highs
um because you know we had paypal news
more every day we hear more and more
companies are getting into bitcoin
whether it's microstrategy or
square um you know we saw bitcoin
obviously pumped straight after
the paypal news so we've had a
retracement things are going back
up again i'm really positive about
everything but let's say your thoughts
um you're gonna hate me i'm like i'm on
yes
i'm on the fence i'm on a fence um hear
me out on this so
i love all the good news i love all the
goodness paypal was just like oh my god
that's crazy right not
like and also you have to read between
the lines with paypal right because
people are like originally pointing out
the limitations of what paypal
service can do but then now you hear
acquisitions
possible acquisitions about bitcoin and
um
you can kind of see the what they're
trying to build right because you never
you should never trust companies for
what they say they are doing right now
but
what they're trying to do right and like
that's the strategy going forward like
the vision
so so that's kind of interesting but at
the same time i've
also pulled a little bit of breaks over
it because i feel like
everyone being so bullish makes me
bearish oh
okay because like you on twitter you you
see
everyone reposting retweeting bearish
comments and i'm guilty of reading that
sometimes too right i'm like oh i'm just
gonna make a
bullish comment and call up like that's
my social media work for today right
and that's when i'm bullish right so but
right now like i'm i'm kind of a little
bit more quiet because like okay look
if everyone is this bearish and
especially like i hear people in my
channel
yeah this but this bullish everyone's so
bullish they're like oh bitcoin is going
to hit 25k no no no
250k don't be joking idiot no no no 1
million
right so then you're like okay look
look look look look look listen listen
listen
if everyone is so
bullish all right and the expectations
are this high
right what if they don't get met
all right so so i didn't i didn't
completely move out like before i freak
everyone out i just
i just want to mess with people too like
when i say this people think like oh i
sold everything no i didn't so
i took um around 20 of my alts just out
just like you know what um the reason
being is because right now the focus is
i think everyone knows the focus is on
bitcoin and ethereum
because we just had two massive runs on
d5 right so
great um d-risk there you know that's
that's a new phrase i learned recently
d-risk
it sounds much better than dump right
i'm gonna
i'm gonna de-risk i'm gonna de-risk some
all coins
um and then bought some bitcoin so so
don't don't kill me here bitcoins it's
good it's good i believe in it but i
still
also hold some stable coins so
i said this um monday so a few people
were a little like a little bit
uneasy that i said this but you know it
did go down a bit and i did
i'm slowly starting to reinterpret just
in case you know like
um you know that made some money there
so that's good i think i'm actually
quite a little bit more optimistic so
just to update everyone so i said that
on monday and then everyone freaked out
so it's still my general sentiment but i
do see some positive real news coming
out
of asia so recently singapore dbs
accidentally you know accidentally i'm
not sure how accidental or not but they
leaked a new service that allows people
to buy crypto and we
i think this is almost real because dbs
has a reputation of allowing more
crypto customers than everyone else so i
feel like that
could be uh something that they're
building but they obviously deleted that
kind of crypto service from their
website like immediately right so i
can't
prove it for myself it was like up for a
second then i was gone
but you know that hit the news and then
we saw some like real like that's what
i'm looking for i'm
looking for real signs that to be
bullish right
so to keep that momentum up right
because to to really hit 25k like you
know everyone's like talking 25k 250k
you got
you got to have some serious legs right
you got to have some serious punches to
throw
before hitting there and i think that's
that's what i'm looking for
so but but that aside though i mean how
do you
feel about bitcoin in general because do
you i mean it sort of isn't
clear whether you even think it's gonna
ever reach new highs
we need legs together i mean absolutely
but i think um the objective of saying
this is not to make people bearish or
whatnot but to make
people think reasonably because i think
if everyone thinks reasonably then we
can move up i think that's my
subconscious mind
it's my mind trick right the jedi mind
trick here like yo
think bitcoin is going to go down and
then it's going to go up but if you keep
thinking it's going to go up guys
that's the one direction to go down so i
feel like bitcoin has a lot of potential
i think that's pretty abundantly clear
you know we don't make content
endlessly on this space if we think it's
going to go down all right let's
let's let's calm down listen to this
listen listen all right so i still have
like a huge bitcoin bags
um i still hold a lot of all coins too
all right so and in fact i'm still
investing heavily in this space too
but at the same time i'm definitely
holding myself back a little bit more
than i was during the d5 days and i
think that's
absolutely necessary um did i regret or
not because i mean obviously i was still
holding myself back
and i didn't ape as hard as i should
into
keeper so maybe that's my punishment for
not
being a little bit more conservative but
i'm okay with that you know yeah
yeah you gotta hedge yourself against
some risk there but um
lots of questions i have so i'm just
still trying to understand your
perspective on bitcoin i know you still
hold big bags
but you know do you i mean do you even
think it could get to new heights
i feel like you're absolutely slowly
okay good i wasn't gonna say that wasn't
obvious
okay okay okay i think i think i think i
stepped on a gas tour um stops i stepped
on the brakes too early i think i'm just
kind of i'm kind of just like the people
who think
bitcoin is gonna be like 25k you know
in a month you know like right right
okay not bad
but i definitely think like bitcoin is
fundamentally
right it's fundamentally poised to move
up and that's why i'm holding huge bags
i mean you know that's
that's clear okay cool because i mean
i'm gonna you know i was gonna say if we
look at the average year on year it's
just getting higher whether
there's no wild bull run or whatever
just year on year
obviously like that's yeah that's that's
the obvious you're stressing out for a
sec
and also like i think that's what i do
also is i'm kind of a dick like that
like i stress people out
in their response like if they're if
they're concerned i'm panicking i'm like
okay you're over
you're over leveraged like okay so it's
all about the balance you're bringing
people back listen
are you are you aggressively leveraged
in bitcoin
confession time confession time right
okay so you mentioned some alts and i
definitely want to talk about that so
when can we see um an old season you
mentioned you're still holding alt so
obviously i'm going to ask you which old
scene you're holding michael um
and everything name one
apart from hex i'm holding everything
i'm just joking oh man that's cause i
had a war with those guys this week but
yeah
oh really you know it spread it very far
okay i see it no i only know because i'm
looking in the comments
no no i'm looking in the comments and
somebody has written box mining
recommended
to avoid the best performing crypto
there we go do not put it on screen
that's what i saw in the comments so
yeah yeah we have this ongoing war best
performing
yeah yeah yeah just go okay actually i'm
not going to go into it i don't want to
go into it
let's not go into it okay back to the
olds so
talk to me what are you holding and what
is your top pick for 2021
oh no i'm not saying that no
comment
no comment no comment let me think let
me think i think it's always um
it's always dangerous to say that i
think i don't know why but for
for some reason this year i haven't
really been aggressively pushing odds i
think
i've said my medium bags already so i'll
repeat that
um in terms of it alt so um i started
off you trust because i think
entry points are important they recently
just released a card uh you're working
on that right
yeah was that the one you were working
on you was a utrust you were working on
i can't remember you
there's two cars there's two cars
there's two cars there's pluto's card
and then there's utrecht card i'm both
available in europe first i'm really
jealous of you guys all right so you
trust and also has payments too so
that's like kind of accepting payments
with merchants then we have swissborg
which is
entry points like um going into crypto
out of crypto so you can buy crypto
easily i think that's a no-brainer
having this infrastructure there if the
bull run is to come
that should be it right um we also have
engines or nfts
i was a little bit disappointed about
engine to be honest um
like they didn't really catch this whole
d5 wave the way they should have
caught it um i mean they're trying to do
something like they have this like
nft awards i'm like
i don't know like they really need to
aggressively push i feel like this is
like their time to shine so
um i've been like yo do some but
you know that's
that's like me push trying to push them
i don't know how much that works
um i also have finance so um bmv was
actually
yeah the topic so i picked that up
around 18 and i told everyone about that
so that was great
um yeah bmb was kind of obvious right
because they need to come back
they need a they really need to push
they have the binary smart chain coming
up they have they're trying to push
their stuff out so
uh that makes sense right i still have
some chain link as well
i think that chain link was like the top
oracle choice for
i'm gonna just pause you on that one
chain link let's just quickly chat about
it because
there's been a lot of noise so do you
think we're actually going to see
another one with chain link
um i mean i remember when it was running
i remember a lot of uh
analysts were sort of saying we could
see 32 by december
i i hate those analysts um
[Music]
look look look look look look we've been
in crypto like
for some time right and anytime the
analyst
says x happened
let me short it okay because um it never
goes
it almost never goes well so there's a
few things with train link i think that
was a very interesting phenomenon and i
heard a lot
i liked a lot didn't like a lot but at
the end of the day i think i made my
piece with it
um so a few things right the from a
fundamental tech perspective
the oracles are very important and i'm
going to cover a lot more about oracle's
and
you know i mean the easiest way to
describe is this right
train link provides data right and that
makes smart contracts smarter
all right smart contracts is only as
smart as the data they get right so at
the end of the day they need data
somehow
so this this whole kind of battle over
kind of the oracle space the providing
data i think that's very important
but the problem of course when it comes
to evaluation like how do you evaluate
the ecosystem the value of said
ecosystem and this is one of the biggest
issues with crypto
right so i feel like this is where
it gets really murky i think chain link
has a lot of very good supporters
they're
very very good at doing partnerships and
the community is very strong so i think
that's
very valuable um they also had this
attack from zeus capital which is very
very interesting
and there's this huge report you know
people trying to flood the crap out of
them so i find i find that very
interesting right like
um maybe there's a you know a little bit
of truth to that too you know how do you
really evaluate the the price right so
people are going to hate me now for
saying that but
i'm kind of in the middle now i'm kind
of saying look you know it definitely
has value
and i don't really care what the
says i'm just going to have a bit of
exposure to it and i think that's the
kind of
the end sentiment i'm gonna have on you
know chain link where
i want to be exposed so i have um
somewhat some exposure
but i'm not gonna be like though crazy
guys who are like oh and let's say
thirty dollars or a hundred i mean you
know come on come on yeah i know i i get
you
stop stop trusting analysts right
yeah no no no i get you and i also think
you know if we believe that d5
is going to take off and if we sort of
think that it's going to continue and
this is just the beginning then i think
there's definitely
um you know a market for oracle's to
provide more data
to make smart contracts smarter as you
put it so i don't know about i don't
know about the
i don't know about the um the
predictions but i'm definitely following
put it that way
um okay so somebody in the comments has
just written v chain i want to get your
thoughts on v chain are you holding
vechain
yeah absolutely actually um vegan was
actually a bigger bag so i put
um bitcoin ethereum and v chain on the
top
uh so that kind of explains it so
bitcoin is like the the one that's like
the the biggest
um ethereum v train uh why vt number
three
is because they are tackling enterprise
right so like
i've been trying to aggressively find
projects that has
a real use case right like um because
you kind of view it this way right
bitcoin has its use case which is
decentralized money
and over these 10 years a lot of
projects have tried to tackle bitcoin's
position as
decentralized money and they pretty much
failed right
um you kind of see you kind of see that
um
all the coins that are arguing that
they're decentralized money they're
slowly dying away right they're slowly
withering away
right because bitcoin is just too
dominant and everyone's using bitcoin
it's become the de facto currency for
decentralized money
so i feel like that's where and why i
hold bitcoin i feel like it doesn't
i think like um it's super hard to
challenge this position because everyone
is using it and the more adoption there
is the harder it is to to
to kind of challenge it right so that's
number one then
ethereum i would don't really view it as
just decentralized money right it's also
running an entire platform because it's
turning complete
it allows for decentralized finance
right like
the whole d5 revolution started because
of ethereum and the
ethereum is the og one there right so
and also with ethereum it's also the
case where
a lot of projects try to replace it but
they can't
because if there has such a strong both
community where
speculators and also um long-term
huddlers
and also developers which is very very
core as well
so a huge amount of development i mean
think about a unit swap
all the wi-fi stuff whether it's keeper
or whatever that's coming out all this
decentralized stuff that's all like
on ethereum they're going to create as
many things as they want
so ethereum's up there then of course v
chain is more the enterprise side i mean
if you think about it
one of the biggest values you can create
in the space
is with being able to provide
authenticity so having this kind of
direct
application of it right so beach india
already developed a lot of products
where you can just like say
you put your phone nfc tag scan a device
and
immediately queries it finds a tag id
queries the blockchain to find out where
it's been how it's been going and you
can precisely track how it got to
and this is actually very powerful
because like for luxury goods and stuff
we're like very worried about
counterfeits
and even for logistics supply chains and
stuff like
being able for these tags to work in
tandem with blockchain i feel like
that's like the low-hanging fruit for
adoption
but obviously that being said it still
takes a lot of time i think a lot of
people are like oh my god it's
it's been a year you know guys it's been
a year
when moon and i think that's that's it
does take time you know it does take
time so i feel like that's
the the situation is that now where um i
think that's kind of the
core i put it away and i forget about it
and then i kind of just play
with all these weird adults which is
hilarious
so you know we talk about deep eye and
nfts and all this stuff and ethereum so
ethereum obviously we know at this point
cannot necessarily scale just because
you know we saw what happened with
cryptokitties
when it was under that kind of scaling
pressure so when do you think we're
going to see ethereum 2.0 and do you
think ethereum 2.0 will actually be able
to you know
you talk about that the fruit you know
hanging
mass adoption kind of analogy do you
think it could actually make this happen
i think that's a question on everyone's
minds um but
two things right so um if 2.0 is going
to launch
but e 2.0 was promised to us when
i was making videos too right so not to
flood everything for anyone who likes
eve like i have to be so careful now
what i say because i can sometimes sound
like a douchebag and then now i'm
i don't know why but i'm trying to
sometimes i intentionally
push people's buttons but just just be
aware of that okay so sometimes you get
your buttons pushed
sometimes i might just be a dick all
right we'll take it with a pinch of salt
take it with a pinch of salt so um you
know i was making
um if videos if 2.5 2.0 videos when it
was back in 2017 so it's been a long
time
that being said we actually saw some
really good developments this year so
for example
uh we actually have like the beacon
chain up so
phase 0 of ethereum 2.0 i have a whole
video on it um
so eve 2.0 i think um
it won't be what people expect because
phase zero doesn't scale at all
right that's not it's not to create
scaling it's create randomness
so once eve 2.0 starts it's it's the
beginning rather than the end
of the scaling issue so if it's
it's not going to be and this is where
eve 2.0 is on train scaling it's going
to battle off chain scaling
with optimistic rollouts so this is
where
uh if like some people branded this eve
1.5
yeah okay so there there is
zk roll ups and optimistic roll-ups
coming up i'm still
not as versed as i should be on both of
these so
recently i've seen some projects already
deploy some scaling
solutions that rely not on eve 2.0 but
on optimistic rollouts on zk rollout so
for example right now if you look at
curve curve has actually have a test
on zk roll up so yeah so it's actually
pretty awesome so
um hopefully that comes soon i mean yeah
we'll have to see so
um long story cut short i think there
are going to be solutions deployed and i
also do agree with a lot of people who
think that
regardless of if 2.0 or one of these
scaling techniques or even matic for
example right
i think a lot of people are high
problematic but regardless of what we're
going to use some form of scaling on
ethereum to make it
like at least usable for the everyday
user
but that's still i mean it's still a
long journey i think
yeah it's just you just have to wait and
be patient it's hard it's hard it's hard
truths
yeah okay so we are coming up close to
an hour and i don't want to keep you too
long because
it's nearly midnight for you which is
actually insane i'm still not over this
time difference thing
so just finally can you give us your
last words what have you got to say and
i will put you on full screen for this
it was going to be great
go on last words huh um be smart
so you know crypto i think recently i've
been having kind of a lot of thinking
right i think i don't know why but i've
been thinking a lot more
so uh for me personally just like
the more you think um and
plan that helped me a lot so not
financial of course
advice of course but use brain use this
rather than this for me
that kind of works i mean some people
invest with this okay
great good for you um do what works for
yourself but for me i'm always been
thinking
of kind of what's out there what's the
next big thing and that's kind of my
objective personally
um if you want to follow and kind of
what right now i'm
a lot more brutally honest so i feel
like that's kind of the style
i'm trying to do i think that's kind of
fun um
and we've been doing that um on the live
stream so i'll shamelessly promote my
live streams here so
um box mining just search on youtube and
it's on hong kong time
friday mornings and uh monday mornings
so yeah um just search for that you'll
find when the live stream times are and
destroy that community
we also have a very strong telegram
community it was really great um
you know we had a blast on that
community to um
talk about everything new especially
when um andre dropped
um keep pronouncing kind of crazy so
that's the only discussion we've been
having for
some time so anyway so if you guys want
to join us just join youtube and
eventually
get an invite to telegram it's like it's
kind of exclusive now which is great
but it was all free and you know it's
all free and everyone will we'll find a
way to
let everyone in like all the cool people
in and that's awesome so
yeah that's pretty much what i want to
say that was putting me on my spot
also but that was cool but i thought it
was great you put me on the spot earlier
so that was great
okay that's brilliant and i think you
know it's super important you know a lot
of people do ambassador with their heart
instead of their head so the best with
your head
do you ever trade with your head and uh
and sort of leave your heart for
you for yourself anyway i want to thank
you so much it's been such a pleasure
i'm going also to thank blockfy they're
my sponsors and also i want to give a
quick shout out
to bitcoin jimbo you guys should follow
him he does all my channel art so
if you are interested in um getting some
cool thumbnails some cool graphic
designs getting a logo
hit up um bitcoin jimbo he's really cool
and he's in australia so he's just
typical guy anyway
thank you everyone michael thank you so
much i will see you all
next thursday and i have a really cool
guest then so goodbye over and out